that's how they
called trump donald, I'll make friends with me
to call him Vladimir, but I mean that
you communicated with four American presidents
when it was more than your eyes that
obama read something, in my opinion, he didn’t really
rise to the ranks, well, with Gil from the shortest of these
four was the most no now  to say to these
pipes it wasn’t quite, in
fact, quite a constructive relationship,
clogs, we didn’t fly, flew, didn’t
fly,
so I had good ones, you’ll have a good story,
but he quarreled, yes no, and
there is a quarrel just when a person
says that my mother’s about the pressure chamber and
grabar  fence, but he already said that the
Americans are their special nation
and they almost have a special exclusive right,
but I can’t agree with this, the
Lord created everyone the same with the
same rights, and therefore to say
that someone has an exclusive for something
seems to me absolutely not  justified
if how to build a five-point scale
so that it is not more difficult at what level they are
now with the Americans in relations with the
Americans  antsy,
but it seems to me somewhere, but it will go a
C grade
shorter, the room is not bad, yes, between the
two, which is closer to the top three, everything, but
I looked at you to look, and we
are still
cooperating in the field of combating
terrorism, I really, because I will call
it I  trump called to say
thank you for passing
this information on to us, but if this is a
St. Petersburg cell before which they
worked for them for a long time, then the FBI did
this, this information was transferred, that is, the
Americans work better for us, our
territories, they work for me, I won’t
now  to say because this is classified
information,
they work globally, I won’t tell anyone,
well, well, but I’ll whisper in my ear the garage about
it doesn’t work globally like we do,
but they caught it in this situation,
ours didn’t catch ours much
and they warn dozens of
terrorist attacks and don’t  lives
snatched out about there the account goes to
low dozens a year, this situation of the
American was monitored, thank you very much